et le chaos au premier jour de 2023
dimanche dans cet hôpital pour enfants
de Helson le personnel est à pied
d'oeuvre pour nettoyer les débris
quelques heures seulement après
l'attaque
autour de minuit après le discours du
président
le bombardement a commencé
le rez-de-chaussée
et le deuxième étage
ont été touchés environ 7 fois
les chirurgiens opéré un adolescent de
13 ans au moment du bombardement le
garçon avait été gravement blessé
quelques heures plus tôt dans un village
voisin il a été transféré dans un
hôpital de nicolaïve à 100 km d'ici des
attaques à Herson mais aussi à Kiev
peu après minuit dans la capitale les
sirènes sont suivies d'une série
d'explosions sur ces photos de débris de
drone publiés par les autorités
ukrainiennes les mots bonne année sont
écrits en russe dans la journée de
dimanche l'armée ukrainienne a abattu 35
ans explosifs
dont des droneshad de fabrication
iranienne lundi à l'aube qui a fêté
encore visé par des frappes aériennes
ils ont peur ils ont raison car ils sont
en train de perdre les drones les
missiles Ryan pourra les aider car nous
sommes ensemble et ils ne sont uniques
par la peur
Moscou affirme de son côté avoir ciblé
des installations de fabrication de
drones ukrainiens